quand je suis né au milieu des années 50
le monde était simple en fait il était
cloisonné organisé structuré ce qui se
passait en chine
ça ne concernait pas vraiment c'était
des romans on avait l'industrie d'un
côté on avait le service de l'autre et
du coup une organisation hiérarchique et
pyramidale simple structure et avait un
sens est d'ailleurs vous voyez là à
quatre ans on m'apprenait déjà empilés
une pyramide et c'est le monde dans
lequel on vivait simplement depuis les
années 50 il s'est passé quelques
petites choses sur ces dernières
décennies pour prendre simplement un
exemple ce qui se passe en chine nous
concerne aujourd'hui
deuxième exemple on nous parle de l'ubs
et risation mais l'ubs et risation
aujourd'hui elle ne parle que de taxi et
d'hôtels c'est finalement pas beaucoup
de choses il ya peut-être quelques
hôteliers ou quelques chauffeur taxi il
m'en excuse rompt donc pour eux c'est
les concernent
mais pour l'ensemble de l'économie la
révolution numérique
elle n'a pas commencé c'est un peu comme
si on était imaginé on né le 26 décembre
2004 sur la plage de phuket et on trouve
que la mer est mauvaise on ferait bien
de se rendre compte du tsunami qui
arrive donc nous avons un tsunami
numérique qui est en train d'arriver qui
va arriver
alors face à un tsunami numérique
si on reste pyramidale centralisée
rigide on va casser
vous connaissez tous la fable du chêne
et du roseau le chêne casse
et donc mon propose ce soir c'est
effectivement d'expliquer pourquoi il
est urgent pourquoi il est indispensable
dès 2017 d'entreprendre un vrai
changement pour sortir de cette culture
qui date des années 50 pyramidale et qui
bloque les évolutions alors cette
structure pyramidale
elle vient de très loin elle vient de
quatre siècles
louis xiv caisse café louis xiv pour
asseoir son pouvoir il a pris les nobles
il les a enlevées du territoire et il a
créé un lieu fictif qui s'appelle
versailles donc il a créé un lieu de
pouvoir hors sol qui n'était plus
connecté au monde réel au monde que
vivaient les français et on a continué
derrière la révolution c'est les
jacobins qu'on gagne et napoléon on a
rajouté une couche importante et pour
faire court de boules une dernière donc
on est resté dans cette culture de
l'homme miracle ou de la femme miracle
et bien quand un tsunami arrive il n'y a
pas d'hommes et de femmes miracle la
solution ne peut pas venir d'un système
rigide et centralisée d'autant plus que
cette classe politique hors sol et je
fais bien la distinction avec les élus
locaux je parle de ceux qui sont dans
des bureaux parisiens
elle ne connaît pas les territoires la
seule chose qu'elle connaisse et des
moyennes elle ne sait faire que des
calculs mathématiques
or un taux d'inflation un taux de
croissance un taux de chômage ou un pib
ça ne veut rien dire
cédée entité mathématiques théorique
je ne sais pas si l'un quelconque de
vous quand il a auchan va regarder le
taux d'inflation pour savoir s'il va
pouvoir remplir son caddie
je ne pense pas la réalité les dans les
territoires
la deuxième chose c'est que cette
centralisation elle détruit trois
petites choses
la liberté l'égalité et la fraternité la
liberté puisque elle nous l'a confisqué
légalité parce que comme elle raisonne
par moyenne pour qu'un raisonnement par
moyenne fonctionne il faudrait d'abord
passer la france au bulldozer
mais tout à plat et ensuite prendre les
65 millions de français pour faire en
sorte d'avoir une population homogène
sur chaque territoire
hélas une politique par les moyens de
fonctionner quand on applique une
politique par les moyennes sur un
territoire et des territoires
hétérogènes on est les plus forts et on
affaiblit les plus faibles donc on
détruit de l'égalité troisième point
quand on a une politique centralisée et
vertical on a des cheminées étanche
donc on n'a pas de fraternité on n'a pas
des gens qui travaillent ensemble donc
il est indispensable j'y reviens après à
passer des territoires parce que c'est à
partir des territoires qu'on peut
construire la liberté l'égalité la
fraternité
à l'opposé de cette vision il ya une que
j'aime bien qui est celle de pierre
rabhi avec son histoire du colibri à
l'histoire du colibri est la suivante
c'est bien il ya un grand feu dans une
savane et il ya un petit colibri qui
arrêtent pas de prendre trois gouttes
d'eau équipe un saut dans son bec et qui
le jettent sur le feu et puis on est à
tous qu'ils regardent et qui regarde le
colibri qui fait ça sans arrêt et au
bout d'un moment le tattoo idiot colibri
mais franchement je n'ai jamais y
arriver il colibri lui réponds oui mais
j'aurais au moins chez ma part avant
d'aller plus loin je voudrais qu'on
m'éclaire la salle si j'ai deux
questions à vous poser parmi vous la
zurich j'ai pas timide
quels sont ceux qui se retrouvent dans
les partis politiques actuels et je
voudrais qu'ils lèvent la main
de gauche ou de droite fait pas timides
si vous vous retrouvez dans les partis
politiques actuels lever la main je vois
pas beaucoup de mains j'ai une deuxième
question à vous poser
quels sont ceux parmi vous qui ont
vraiment envie que ça change dit
retirant en vie qu'en 2017
il se passe quelque chose de nouveau et
je voudrais vous demander de vous lever
ceux qui ont envie que ça change en 2017
merci
je veux un jour on partage et ça va me
donner un peu un peu d'énergie pour pour
continuer
alors le deuxième mal français c'est nos
organisations collectives
on nous parle sans arrêt du millefeuille
français alors je vous conseille d'aller
à une pâtisserie renseigner sur que ces
cas millefeuille un millefeuille ça à
trois couches clair net distinctes et
avec de la crème pâtissière entre les
trois entre les 3 es le taux est
appétissant si la france était à mille
feuilles ça irait bien non c'est un tas
de spaghettis trop cuit et qui colle
vous tirez sur un bout de spaghettis ça
revient ou si vous préférez un jeu de
mikado revisité par dali ou et essayer
de jouer un jeu de mikado et les tiges
molle
pénélope elle tisser une toile mais la
devesa la nuit nous nos politiques qui
n'arrête pas de la tissés depuis 40 ans
je défie qui que ce soit de façon se
tromper de me dire qu'est ce qui relève
de l'état de la région des départements
des groupements de communes des communes
etc
dernier élément de complexité le grand
paris je me permets même si on est à
lille de citer ce nouveau cas de
complexité
donc ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
le millefeuille est pas le problème
c'est la solution il faut qu'on arrive à
sortir d'un tas de spaghetti pour aller
vers un millefeuille parce qu'en plus
d'un au tas de spaghettis on a une colle
qui s'appelle le paritarisme le
paritarisme
c'est le fait que on est mis les
syndicats patronaux et ouvriers dans la
gestion qu'on les mette dans la
négociation et dans la décision très
bien mais dans la gestion qu'est ce que
ça fait ça fait qu'on peut pas
rapprocher la médecine du travail des
hôpitaux compo parents propre rapprocher
le 1% logement du logement social qu'on
peut pas rapprocher la formation
professionnelle des lycées
professionnels un tas de feuilles
étaient trop cuit
troisième élément c'est vraiment notre
gueule de bois la dépense publique
ça fait des dizaines d'années des
dizaines d'années que on croit qu'il
suffit d'augmenter une dépense publique
pour résoudre des problèmes on a un
problème de chômage ont fait des emplois
aidés on a un prime de logement ont fait
des aides au logement
on a un prénom d'éducation on augmente
le budget de l'éducation
si c'était vrai moi j'ai une solution
assez simple à vous proposer
on va créer deux entreprises on va
commencer modestement une 2000 personnes
qui creuse des trous et une deuxième de
1000 personnes qui bouchent les trous et
là j'écris un système vertueux qui va
régler le problème du chômage et de la
croissance alors on peut penser que mon
propos est caricatural mais quand on
fait des oeuvres d'art inaccessible au
lieu des ronds points
moi j'ai essayé d'y aller avec les
petits enfants âgés créé un bouchon
voilà parce qu'il ya des voitures qui
tournent autour si on fait la somme de
ce qu'on a dépensé en oeuvre d'art
inutile c'est dire je ne parle pas des
coûts des ronds points
c'est des milliards d'euros j'ai vérifié
le chiffre des milliards d'euros qui ont
été dépensés en oeuvre d'art inutile
vous croyez pas que cet argent ils
seraient mieux dans vos poches ou
ailleurs à un endroit où effectivement
on n'a pas mis assez d'argent comme la
justice il ya quelques dizaines d'années
gainsbourg a brûlé un billet de 500
francs à la télévision lassé des liasses
de billets d'euros combes rule 20
milliards en formation professionnelle
pour ne pas être formé 20 milliards dans
le logement pour par hasard le logement
alors comment on peut s'en sortir
et bien pour s'en sortir en fait il faut
changer complètement de mode de pensée
et refonder la france à partir des
territoires à partir des endroits où
vous vivez parce que c'est là qu'on peut
construire une vraie politique de
l'éducation du logement de la santé de
l'emploi et qui partent des territoires
que l'état arrête de dire ce qu'il faut
faire sur les territoires qui
définissent simplement des minimums ce
serait bien le minimum d'ailleurs par
exemple dans l'éducation qu'ils disent
que chaque français ça je dois savoir
lire et écrire à 7 ans
mais qu'ils s après le territoire
trouver sa solution et qui soit un
soutien parce que si je reste sur le
problème de l'éducation
la solution elle va pas être simplement
des enseignants elle va être aussi dans
la capacité de mobiliser des retraités
pour aider à prendre lire et écrire des
associations de sports ou comme on l'a
vu tout à l'heure des gens qui y sont
innovants ou en matière de danse et yako
niveau d'un territoire qu'on veut
trouver ces maillage il ya quelqu'un qui
a bien compris ça il s'appelle alexandre
jardin et qui a entrepris beaucoup
d'actions à travers bleu-blanc zèbres
mais c'est insuffisant aujourd'hui le
territoire français est bloqué donc il
va falloir renverser la table est
effectivement aller prendre un pouvoir
central pour obliger ce pouvoir central
à changer de logique et être dans une
logique de soutien et non plus une
logique de prescripteurs dernier point
je voudrais finir avec un message
d'avenir j'ai de positif j'ai commencé
en parlant de tsunami numérique
j'ai beaucoup voyagé toutes les années
toutes ces dernières années en asie aux
états unis et un peu de partout et
j'aurais parlé de deux endroits
singapour et dubaï singapour c'était la
pointe de la malaisie il ya 40 50 ans
enfin ça l'est toujours d'ailleurs
mais il y avait pas grand chose la ville
a été multiplié par quatre en quelques
dizaines d'années
dubaï ça n'était qu'un que du désert il
n'y avait pas de pétrole pas de revenu
multiplié par 10 en quelques dizaines
d'années ce qui a été fait à dubaï ou à
singapour
peut-être fait ici nous avons infiniment
plus de ressources dans notre territoire
dans nos territoires qu'il y en avait à
dubaï ou à singapour
la france et la proue de l'europe elle
est extraordinairement placé avec ses
façades maritimes le commerce mondial
repose sur des porcs faudrait-il aussi
comprenez que nos ports avec
l'hinterland or on continue à me penser
par heroes
alors qu'il faudrait penser paris en
long et le connecter au havre ici à
lille je suis étonné de voir aussi peu
de projets pour les connexions avec
dunkerque
donc il s'agit de remail et nos
territoires
deuxième grande force de la france en a
de l'espace libre peu de pays l'ont on a
aussi cette diversité de territoires
pour toute personne qui voyage vous
verrez que c'est le seul pays qui
changent tous les 30 50 km
dès que vous faites 50 km en france vous
avez un autre paysage
c'est une force troisième élément nous
avons une population dynamique
nous avons des jeunes nous avons des de
l'année sont des naissances nous avons d
un capital installé nous avons encore
pas mal d'entreprises à la fois des
artisans entreprises moyennes et un
certain nombre de grands groupes
dernier point nous sommes à la pointe
des mathématiques
alors je suis assez critique sur les
mathématiques quand il s'agit de calcul
des taux d'inflation des taux de
croissance c'est ça ne veut strictement
rien dire c'est des moyennes pour faire
des moyennes et quand j'étais petit j'ai
réussi par les mathématiques donc j'ai
pas de jets pas de comptes à régler avec
les mathématiques mais les mathématiques
c'est utile par exemple si vous avez un
votre enfant au moment de la rentrée
scolaire
si vous avez besoin de calculer si vous
avez assez d'argent pour acheter la
trousse c'est pas idiot d'acheter les
mathématiques de calculer et d'utiliser
les mathématiques mais ça n'a rien vous
dire sur ce qu'il va faire et 4 ou 5
donc quand les économistes utilisent les
mathématiques pour savoir si le niveau
de dépenses publiques est suffisant oui
mais quand ils en déduisent ce qui va se
passer avec n'ont donc les mathématiques
il faut les ramener à leur vraie place
mais pourquoi c'est une force parce
qu'on rentre dans le monde de la
technologie de l'information et dans la
technologie de l'information
les mathématiques sont essentiels or
nous avons autant de médailles fields
que les états unis les médailles fields
c'est le nobel donc nous avons tous les
éléments pour construire à partir de
2017 quelque chose d'encore plus beau
que ce qui est derrière moi c'est le
c'est l'hôtel marina bay 1 qu'est le
l'hôtel fétiche de singapour on a des
éléments pour quoi décoiffer largement
plus qu'il qui a été fait à singapour ou
à dubaï mais ça ça suppose qu'en 2017
on renverse effectivement la table et
qui a un vrai réveil citoyen et ça ça
suppose d'une part de prendre ce pouvoir
central mais ça suppose aussi que chacun
fasse sa part parce que sur un
territoire
ça sera de l'action de chacun avec les
autres qu'on pourra à peu près je n'ai
pas compté mais je pense que la totalité
de la salle s'est levée quand j'ai
demandé c'est bien de se lever mais du
coup j'ai une chose à vous demander
c'est que quand vous allez quitter cette
salle ce soir demain la semaine
prochaine dans un mois à l'endroit où
vous êtes dans votre famille dans une
association dans une ville dans un club
vous alliez faire votre part pour que
2010 est sûre effectivement un réveil
citoyen parce que selon de ce dont on a
besoin c'est une alliance des citoyens
debout c'est une alliance des citoyens
qui font leur part c'est une alliance
des citoyens en marche
merci